THINK HIM FROM FOR HUSTLING OVER
HERE.
SO WE DON'T YET HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE I MAY INTERRUPT YOU AT
SOME POINT JUST TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM BUT IN THE MEANTIME
SENATOR DODD IF YOU CAN BEGAN IN
OUR SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE MAKES
TECHNICAL NON SUBSTANTIVE.
NON CONTROVERSIAL FIXES TO AB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHICH WAS
PASSED EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THE BILL HAS NEIJU NEGLIGIBLE
COST NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THINK ILL I SOME SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SARAH BUT ON BEHALF OF CAL
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT.
LARA BENNETT WITH TECHNICIAN
SUPPORT.
KELLY HIT ON BEHALF OF CONTIENE
CONNIE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR KEVIN GOLD
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
CORDY JOHNSON OF CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
PATZ ANSLEY HERE AND WE HAVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WHO SUPPORT THE BILL.
JOANNE BETTENCOURT REPRESENTING
THE SECURITIES INDUSTRY AND
FINANCIAL MARKETS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MY CONSUMERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND SPORT.
MORE IN HE GETS ON BEHALF OF
VIACOM ANTHEM AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
REPUBLICAN TO HAVE THE CONSUMER
DATA INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE REPRESENTING
FORMA IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN KILLINGS INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JERRY MCKEE REPRESENT THE
PACIFIC ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN SUPPORT.
JIMMY WERE WITH A CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
BERNIE ROSCOE OR THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION IN SPORTS.
TERRY THOMAS WITH THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICAN
SPORT.
ALL OF IRAQ ROY CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE --
SENATOR DODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I'M OVERWHELMED THEY'VE
EVER HAD THAT KIND OF SUPPORT ON
ANY BY BILLS.
IT'S JUST FANTASTIC I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WELL I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IF
SOMEBODY WANTS THIS OUT WITHOUT
AS CLOSING THE MEETING THAT THEY
FIND US TO MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WERE TOO SHORT
OF A QUORUM.
I MEAN YOU GUYS BEEN BUGGING ME
ALL DAY SO I AM SURE YOU CAN
FIND SOME WAY.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY ELSE IS EATING
RIGHT NOW.
AND MY STOMACH IS GROWLING.
WE'RE ONE CHOI.
THIS IS A SUPPORT SUPPORT ENJOYS
A DO PASS IT DOESN'T EVEN MATTER.
IF THE RED A BLUE.
WHEN THE LOS?
WHAT IF SUPPORTERS ARE GOING
CRAP AND MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
OTHERS WENT?
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
MONITOR BROUGH [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
PHONE TO HAVE A STRAW THAT
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER GARCIA THEREIN.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK HERE REYES.
THE ESTABLISHES REQUIREMENT DO.
I HAVE A MOTION BY A MYSTERIOUS
A SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW AND
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THE WHOLE RELEVANT FOR TWO
SECONDS.
IRATE THAT ATTORNEYS ARE MEETING